pour cela 18 juin 40 18 juin 2010 il y à
70 ans le général de gaulle lancé son
appel depuis l'on appelle à la
résistance à l'envahisseur nazi
nombreuses cérémonies ont donc eu lieu
aujourd'hui dans la capitale britannique
en présence du président de la
république du prince charles et du
premier ministre david cameron
des cérémonies qui se sont prolongés ce
soir en france et notamment au mont
valérien
bernard lebrun cet homme qui ranime la
flamme a eu 90 ans ailière prix nobel de
médecine
françois jacob fut aussi un fond c'est
libre et il est l'actuel chancelier de
l'ordre des compagnons de la libération
fondé par le général de gaulle sur 1038
compagnon décoré 41 seulement âgé de
plus de 90 ans le plus souvent sont
encore en vie aujourd'hui
dans la clairière de ce fort du mont
valérien pendant la guerre sur exécuter
1014 résistant et opposants à
l'occupation nazie
dès 1946 le général de gaulle a fait de
ce lieu le mémorial de la france
combattante où chaque année se déroule
cet hommage mais pour son 70e
anniversaire
le gouvernement français a voulu faire
les choses en grand dans cet eurostar
spécial arrivant à londres ce matin 850
invités les derniers vétérans de la
france libre surtout siège historique de
la bbc
c'est le couple présidentiel français
qui a fait le déplacement
le studio du général de gaulle n'existe
plus depuis longtemps mais on cultive
ici le souvenir de l'illustre visite nés
après la guerre
nicolas sarkozy 55 ans et david cameron
43 ans ont voulu mettre leurs pas dans
ceux de leurs aînés de gaulle et
churchill en rappelant l'indéfectible
amitié franco britannique en diplomatie
cela va toujours mieux en le disant une
journée également intense pour l'aider